So I really want to spend some time today
talking about what is now.
At first we suspected it, but it's now very
clear is the real possibility of violence.
I'm talking about physical violence.
If Donald Trump were to lose in November and
this is I don't really want to make this about
Trump because it's not this really ties together
sort of the faux populist rhetoric that I've
been warning about.
It ties together Fox News and the propaganda
space.
And in order to talk about this today, we're
going to look at a clip from Tucker Carlson's
program on Monday, I believe it was on Monday
night.
And what I want you to consider here is not
just the growing influence of Tucker Carlson.
And in fact, there are people now talking
about what about Tucker for president in 2024.
If Trump can be president, certainly, at least
theoretically, Tucker Carlson could be president
of the United States.
And I know that that will be very, very scary
to many of you.
But I also want to use the clips we're going
to look at today as a sort of case study in
how the media propaganda cycle works and how
it will completely reverse reality and take
advantage of the lack of education and critical
thinking skills that are part of what got
Donald Trump elected in the first place.
So Tucker Carlson is no longer playing coy.
He is straight up saying the left is dangerous.
The left hates America and the left is a fundamental
threat to the way of life that Tucker, I guess,
espouses through his faux populist rhetoric.
Tucker Carlson, in doing this, is setting
the stage for violence.
If Donald Trump loses, he's both planting
the seed of the idea in the minds of right
wingers, and he's giving right wingers justification
for doing violence.
If Joe Biden were to get elected in November
and the sort of crux of it is the left hates
America.
The left despises this country.
And we're going to look at a segment.
It was a 15 minute segment.
We're going to look at some different pieces
of it.
And after opening up this segment by talking
about how the left only hates Trump because
they can't control him, not because he's incompetent,
not because he's actively damaging the United
States every single day.
Tucker says the left just hates Trump because
they can't control him.
He's a free thinker.
He's an independent mind.
He starts to weave us through this left hates
America idea by saying it starts in school.
School kids aren't taught the history of Mount
Rushmore and Thomas Jefferson that Donald
Trump talked about in his July 3rd Mount Rushmore
speech.
And they're not taught about how the U.S.
is a force for good that defeated fascism
and communism.
It starts in school, Tucker Carlson says.
Take a look.
As the president pointed out, American schoolchildren
learn virtually none of this.
Instead, our curricula have become a toxic
mix of lies and a mission.
All of it designed to poison our children
against the country that formed them.
Against every law, society and nature, our
children are taught in school to hate their
own country and to believe that the men and
women who built it were not heroes, but that
were villains.
The radical view of American history is a
web of lies.
Well.
Perspective is removed, every virtue is obscured,
every motive is twisted.
Every fact is distorted and every flaws magnified
until the history is purged and the record
is disfigured beyond all recognition.
Every word of that is true.
If you have kids in school, you know, it may
even be understatement.
What is happening in our classrooms right
now and 2020 is a crime.
It is long past time that a sitting president
said so.
So why am I starting with the stuff about
schools?
Why is Tucker starting with the stuff about
This is how you start priming the right towards
violence.
Our schools have been taken over by liberal
lies and liberal liars.
Trump is saying it.
And Tucker is willing to say it.
And that's the framework for what is going
to come.
Now, the reason this is so pernicious is that
our schools are failing.
It is true that much of our education system
is not working, but it's failing, as evidenced
by Trump being elected.
In other words, it's failing, as evidenced
by 60 plus million people falling for the
obviously false talking points of the Trump
campaign in 2015 and 2016 and voting for him.
So there is a big problem with our schools.
But the problem is, and our kids are being
taught what I guess Tucker and Trump say is
some incorrect version of history.
Our schools are failing and that American
students are falling further and further behind
behind in math and science compared to many
other countries.
Our schools are failing in that critical thinking
and civics and media literacy are all but
gone unless you're really lucky or seek them
out at some narrow slice of the school of
public schools.
And because of that, 60 million Americans
voted for Donald Trump.
But people fall for stuff like we have 15
cases of corona virus, which will soon be
zero.
Right.
That that's the evidence that education is
failing.
People fall for these bogus tax cuts that
are really you get a little more money in
your paycheck, but your refund is smaller
at the end of the year.
Millions of people fell for that.
So this is how Tucker lays the groundwork.
Schools cannot be trusted and schools are
ruining our kids and turning them against
our country.
Now we go to the next part of this monologue.
Skipping ahead a couple of minutes, Tucker
starts ginning up the hatred with dog whistles,
starts up again with the violent protests.
Check out how he transitions here.
If you spent the rest of your life trying
to locate to identify the worst people in
this country of 330 million, you couldn't
get a pure distillation than what you just
saw.
These people are liars.
They are the same people who've spent the
last month telling you that the riots you
saw live on television were actually peaceful
protests against racism.
That was a lie.
They knew what was a lie when they said it,
but they said it anyway in order to undermine
a country that they hate.
Yes.
Hate America deserves to be in flames.
That is their view.
And this weekend, they said it essentially
out loud.
No one said that riots and looting were peaceful.
Protesting what we said was which is true.
We had overwhelmingly peaceful protests against
police brutality.
And in addition to that, there were some looters
and there were some rioters.
And I can only speak for myself, but I didn't
say that that was evidence of peaceful protesting.
The peaceful protesting was peaceful, protesting.
The other stuff was other things.
But now you see the big picture, the narrative
that Tucker Carlson is weaving, and I admit
it, he does it well.
These are well scripted monologues where,
listen, schools are teaching kids to hate
America.
That was part one.
Then those kids become leftwing rioters who
go out and destroy our cities because they've
been taught to hate America.
So he's building up the justification for
violence if Donald Trump were to lose.
And then he goes fully into it.
The left hates America.
That is the next part of the message.
And if Tucker convinces his audience that
the left hates America, violence against the
left in their eyes would be justified because
it would be protecting America.
And that's where Tucker keeps going and comes
full circle now with Joe Biden.
This is a clever monologue.
This is, you know, because a lot of the people
who watch these programs lack the basic critical
thinking and epistemology skills and media
literacy skills.
This is a far more clever monologue than most
of Tucker's viewers are going to be able to
pick apart for what it is.
You start with our schools, teach kids to
hate, which has led the left to hate America
and go and riot.
And then that same left, who hates America,
wants to elect Joe Biden.
And that's how he links it all together to
Joe Biden and lays the groundwork for violence
if Biden wins.
Take a look.
So where is Joe Biden on all of this as the
revolution continues apace?
Biden is supposed to be a moderate.
Remember, that was his chief appeal.
But there was nothing moderate about Biden,
this Fourth of July statement.
Instead, it was a full throated attack on
the United States.
Our country is founded on an idea we hope
the.
Truths to be self-evident, that all men are
created.
Never lived up to it.
Jefferson himself did, he held slaves.
Women were excluded.
American history is no fairy.
He's been a constant push and pull between
two parts of our character.
The idea that all men and women, all people
are created equal.
And the race has torn us apart.
You've a chance to rip the roots of systemic
racism out of this country.
That's your Fourth of July message, systemic
racism, something you can't even define that
has no real definition, really wagging your
finger in the face of the nation that promoted
someone as mediocre as you to the position
you currently hold.
This is the man who could soon be our figurehead.
So now you've seen the full path.
The left hates our country because schools
are teaching them, too.
After learning to hate the country, they go
out and attack the country by rioting and
looting.
And then they will support Joe Biden, who
is supportive of that America hatred and rioting
and looting.
He's suggesting the imagery of a Joe Biden
presidency as a presidency equivalent to tantamount
to hating America and rioting and looting
and then on the tail end.
Tucker wraps it up with this sort of faux
modest statement of, you know, on this program,
we really try not to question people's patriotism
because that's a really serious thing to do.
But we have to because clearly these people
hate the country.
Take a look at that.
So what to make of all of this?
What's long been considered out of bounds
to question a person's patriotism?
It's a very strong charge.
And we try not ever to make it.
But in the face of all of this, the conclusion
can't be avoided.
These people actually hate America.
There's no longer a question about that.
And yet, paradoxically, at the same time,
they desperately want to control America more
than anything.
And that leads to the most basic of all questions.
Can you really lead a country that you hate?
Ask yourself, what kind of parent would you
be if you hated your children?
What kind of officer would you make if you
didn't care about your troops?
It would be awful.
The results would be ugly.
It would not work.
Loving the people you lead, caring deeply
about them is the most basic prerequisite
of leadership.
The leaders of today's Democratic Party do
not.
They despise this country.
They have said so.
They continue to.
That is shocking, but it is also disqualifying.
We cannot let them run this nation because
they hate it.
Imagine what they would do if they hate America
is the fundamental message.
So the right is falling for this hook, line
and sinker, and it is so unhinged that it
actually could bring the right to violence.
If Joe Biden wins, if you believe, Tucker,
about this, if you sit there for the 13 and
a half minutes or however long it is and you
not along and you say your schools are teaching
his kids to become protesters who riot and
then elect Joe Biden, if Trump loses on November
3rd and you believe that you might feel justified
in going out with your guns to try to put
a stop to this America hatred from the left.
And this gets us back to something that I've
now had to bring up three or four times, which
is the populist rhetoric bamboozles people.
When I talked a few six weeks ago, maybe about
how I'm worried that left populist rhetoric
may be replacing the actual set of ideas,
that is social democracy.
The main concern was the rhetoric sounds pretty
damn good and it's very similar rhetoric from
left to right when it comes to populism.
The middle class is the core of this country
and we need to support the average person
in all of this different stuff.
This is exactly what I'm talking about.
Because then they slip in the prescription,
which is no leftists, conservative school
agendas, no immigrants.
Black Lives Matter will take your house.
The prescription is absolutely bonkers.
And notice that Tucker doesn't talk about
policy.
And when Tucker bragged in the monologue,
I don't know if I played it, but it was in
the monologue.
Tucker said Trump's speech at Mount Rushmore
was one of the best of his presidency.
Tucker said you'll notice that that speech
at Mount Rushmore had essentially no policy
ideas.
It was Trump railing against Marxists who
don't exist.
There's no prominent Marxist that Trump is
reasonably fighting against.
He railed against anarchists on the left.
He railed against people who teach our kids
to hate America.
There were no lists.
There was no list of accomplishments of what
Trump did.
Other than, you know, lies about defeating
the virus, which we clearly haven't done.
And there was no sort of guidebook for what
you would get policy wise from Trump in his
second term.
This is the epitome of being bamboozled by
populist rhetoric.
No policy.
And Tucker says that was a great speech.
Trump really laid it out.
All Trump laid out is an imaginary enemy,
a straw man from the left of these violent
Marxist anarchists, which don't exist.
And then Trump then has the benefit of Tucker
going to his audience and saying that was
a great speech.
Was an amazingly good speech that Donald Trump
gave, all Trump said is the left is radical
and hates everybody and blah, blah, blah,
and respect our heritage again, another allusion
to Confederate statues and the Confederate
flag.
So this is extremely dangerous and it's particularly
dangerous for two reasons.
One, I don't I'm not trying to insult people
when I say this, but the lack of critical
thinking and and media literacy skills in
this country makes this stuff really effective.
That monologue already has like a million
and a half views on YouTube.
And there are people on the right and even
some on the left who are getting tricked into
sharing this Tucker Carlson stuff.
So we've got to do something about it.
I don't even know what it is because the audience
that he is catering to with this garbage is
ripe for it.
They're not going to then come and watch me
spend 15 minutes explaining to you how you're
being bamboozled by this.
So I if I don't sound optimistic, it's because
I'm not I don't know what the solution is
and it's extraordinarily dangerous.
What's going on?
I want to hear your thoughts about it.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that you can get the full audio podcast
of the show every day on whatever your favorite
podcasting platform is, be at Spotify or Pandora
or I iTunes or Google Play.
It's free.
Get the daily podcast and the next Tuesday,
two big things going on on Tuesday.
Number one, the third David Pakman show chess
tournament at 8:00 p.m. Eastern on Tuesday.
You can register for free at David Pakman
dot com slash chess and the number two.
We took a big hit on membership's in the last
week.
We're trying to dig out from a hole of like
300 cancelations.
So Tuesday, the same day as the chess tournament.
We're going to do a one day membership special
where we will email out to everybody on our
mailing list, a very exclusive one day discount
code by exclusive.
It just means you've got to be getting our
newsletter.
You can sign up to be notified on David Pakman
dot com upper right of the Web site.
Type in your email address.
Sign up for the newsletter.
You'll be notified very powerfully on Tuesday.
And then I hope you'll join us for the chess
tournament as well.